and later on could we just say how
pleased we are that Bill's here at all
because yes was a time when you were
dead that's right I know I'm looking a
lot better now no well this is this is
referring to the fact that I was
mistakenly reported as dead on the BBC
website I know it was a BBC website and
it just said tributes pouring in for
actor and comedian musician Bill Bailey
who has died at the age of 52 which is
really annoying because they got the age
wrong
firstly I'm so annoyed about that and
they use a weird photo as well as I mean
perfect for obituaries that is that says
that says this sucks that says sad isn't
it sad it was a bit of a shock to read
that in the morning on Twitter what
happened was that the actual story was
there was a DJ in Kentucky called Bill
Bailey who died and someone on the BBC
was watching the news I get I think what
happened was it was that middle of the
night and they thought Bill Bailey died
and panicked I put Bill Bailey died and
put a photograph up and then realized it
wasn't me
and then panicked again and tried to
delete it but which time somebody taken
a screen shot already and posted it on
Twitter
and the reaction was I was woke at the
money he said Bill Bailey dead 52 and
then my tour manager who was in the
hotel he phoned me
and he said are you all right it's very
sweet but you know well I'm not dead
[Applause]
[Music]
you